- Bennedict Mathurin,
from Montreal!
- La vie de Bennedict Mathurin
a changé à jamais jeudi soir.
Le voilà propulsé sous
les projprestigieuse ligue de bl
du monde.
BENNEDICT MATHURIN,
joueur Pacers de l'Indiana
jouer dans la NBA. Je sais que
mon frère, qui est au paradis et
cette période. Alors,
c'est quelque chose
et j'ai vraiment hâte.
- À 12 ans, Mathurin a perdu
son frère, heurté à mort par une
à vélo. Après un passage à
l'Académie de la NBA au MexiBA ,
il a suivi les traces
universitaire américain.
Deux saisons passées en Arizonaa
plus tard, il rejoint
trois Montréalais dans la NBA.nz
Dort, Chris Boucher et Khem
Birch n'ont jamais été repêchés.
JOEY McKITTERICK,
ancien entraîneur de Mathurjoues
de Montréal, ils sont tous
rentrés par la porte
d'en arrière. Pour Ben,
il a ouvert la porte, je pense.
sa casquette, donner la main
au commissaire.
C'était "prime time TV",
CHRISTINE BLACK, mairesse de
l'arrondiss. de Moiss. de Moissd
- C'est extraordinaire pour lui,
pour toute notre communautéousos
savez, entre autres, Bennedict
est un jest un jest un jest un s
soutenu par la communauté,
entre autres par son école......
- À Montréal-Nord, Mathurin
est devenu un exemple et une
inspiration pour les jeunes
et aussiJEAN-LUC ESTIMABLE,
amateur de basketball
- Ces jeunes-là qui rêvent
d'être "draft", qui rêvent
"step" pour eux. C'est...
C'est "huge".
C'est vraiment gros.ALEXANDRE,
amateur de basketball
- Ça montre qu'à Montréal,
il y a du talent et il y a
du potentiel, puisplus
là-dedans.
RICARDO JEANTY,
joueur de basketball
- C'est quelqu'un qui était
avec nou avec lui.
C'est fou, là, il est devenu...
des millions
maintenant.
- Au cours des prochaines
n contrat de quatre ans
qui lui rapportera environ25 mit
peut-être que le début.
Ici Antoine Desha